new this morning today is national
kindergarten day and the state is hoping
that no matter the age of your kiddo
you'll start thinking about college that
has a unique program that gives each
public school student in the state 50
dollars in a college savings account for
free
we want to kick-start the conversation
around savings for college whether or
not that's saving through one of our 529
plans which are tax advantage programs
kind of like 401ks but for college or
through nevada prepaid which is an
incredible program that'll actually
allows you to pay today's rates for
college and lock it in for whenever
the child goes to school
even if you're not able to grow the
account yourself nevada state treasurer
zach conan there says there are a lot of
ways to achieve higher education through
state and federal grants and
scholarships this is really just the
start the nevada college kickstart
program it started in 2013 it is the
largest in the country in fact right now
there are 277 000 accounts so where does
that free money come from
it's not taxpayer money we actually get
paid for our services by folks that
aren't nevadans who invest uh in nevada
and our college savings plan because
they're so good we have about 37 billion
dollars worth assets and the proceeds
that we make off that we get to give
back to nevadans in the form of college
kickstart and other great programs we
have a link at 8newsnow.com so that you
can get to the treasurer's website on
the home page there's a button called
nevada college kickstart and that's
where you sign up you log in it is that
easy